[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: ONE AM I DOING?
ALL YOU PEOPLE STOP IT, STOP IT.
IT DON'T STOP IT.
OKAY, HAPPY WEDNESDAY WE ARE
JUST FIVE DAYS INTO KEVIN
McCARTHY'S TENURE AS SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE IS ARTIE BECOME MY
FAVORITE KEVIN BEHIND KEVIN
SPACEY.
AS YOU KNOW IT SO IS PREFERABLE
TO BE BEHIND KEVIN SPACEY.
OF COURSE, IT TOOK 15 BALLOTS TO
CONFIRM McCARTHY WHICH POINTED
ONLY THIS IS TO MONITOR
JOE BIDEN TO BECOME PRESIDENT.
YES SUMI.
BUT WHILE WE WERE VOTING AND
REBUILDING HE WAS PROVING THAT
REVENGE MUCH LIKE THE FRUITY
PEBBLES BILL FEEDS ME IN THE
MORNING.
AS A DISH BEST SERVED COLD.
WAS DIFFERENT THIS TIME AS
REPUBLICANS LEARN SOMETHING FROM
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ARE KEEPING THEIR PROMISES
AND FIGHTING LIKE FIENDS.
ON TUESDAY, THEY TOOK STEPS TO
BOOST OVERSIGHT OF BOTH THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
GRANTED IT'S HARD TO TELL THE
TWO APART.
FIRST THEY APPROVE SUBCOMMITTEE
TO PROBE THE --
I HATE THAT WORD.
WEAPONIZATION IT'S OVERUSED JUST
SAY EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
INVESTIGATING.
ABUSES AGAINST THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
DOES THE GOVERNMENT COLLECT INFO
ON OR OTHERWISE INVESTIGATE IN
THE CITIZENS OF THE U.S.?
AND HOW DEEP WAS THAT COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE FBI AND PRIVATE
SECTORS TO BAN SPEECH AT THE
WHITE HOUSE DISAGREE WITH?
HOUSE REPUBLICANS HAD A PLAN TO
ADDRESS THREATS FROM CHINA.
LIKE SENTINEL, A TAX ON THE
POWER GRID, AND UNDER SPICED
THAT SUITS.
THE G.O.P. IS ALSO KLEIN BAG
BILLIONS THAT WOULD FINIS 87,000
NEW EMPLOYEES TO HARASS
FREELANCERS, SMALL BUSINESSES,
AND THE ORPHANS WHO MANAGE MY
OFFSHORE BANK ACCOUNTS.
[LAUGHTER]
REST IN PEACE ORPHANS.
IF JOE BIDEN WANTS TO GET BLOOD
FROM A STONE HE SHOULD DO A FACE
PLANT BIKE RIDING AGAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
ALL THAT PROBABLY WASN'T EVEN
THE BEST THING THAT McCARTHY
DID THIS WEEK.
YES, IT'S TIME TO...
♪ ♪
>> IS IN A BLISS.
THEY ARE GOING AWAY.
THE WORST POLITICIANS AROUND AND
NOW THEY CAN'T STAY.
SEND OUT THE CLOWNS.
[APPLAUSE]
THESE PEOPLE ARE [BLEEP] CLOWNS.
>> Greg: YOU GET TO LIVE
ANOTHER DAY GENE.
YEP, FROM THE HOUSE COMMITTEES.
THE BRIGHT SPOT FOR OMAR'S WHEN
SHE BREAKS THE BAG NEWS TO HER
HUSBAND AND HER BROTHER SHOULD
ONLY HAVE TO MAKE ONE PHONE
CALL.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
IT NEVER GETS OLD.
[LAUGHS]
McCARTHY PROMISED TO COME
AFTER THEM AND UNLIKE THE
FLATULENT FLUNKY IT WASN'T JUST
HOT AIR.
HE SAYS, CAN'T GET A SECURITY
CLEARANCE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
I'M NOT GOING TO GIVE HIM THE
GOVERNMENT SECURITY CLEARANCE.
IN HER DEFENSE NO ONE WOULD HIRE
HIM IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
IF A BEAUTIFUL IS INTERESTED IN
YOU, SHE'S EITHER A SPY,, OR AS
LOST HER SENSE OF SMELL.
[APPLAUSE]
FINALLY, IT'S TRUE.
THERE'S HIS HAPLESS ADAM SCHIFF
IS MANUFACTURED MORE LIES THAN
THE COSMETIC INDUSTRY.
McCARTHY VOWS THAT WE WILL NOT
ALLOW HIM TO BE ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE EITHER.
ALSO ADD ANYTHING ELSE THAT HAS
THE WORD INTELLIGENCE IN THE
TITLE.
WE ASKED HIM TO COMMENT.
>> MAY NO LONGER BE CHAIRMAN BUT
I CAN STILL FEEL LIKE ONE WITH
MY NEW STRAP ON CHAIRMAN'S
CHAIR.
WITH HER WALKING DOG, GET IN THE
MAIL BILLS.
JUST HAVING FUN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: NICELY DONE.
SO McCARTHY SAID THAT HE WOULD
RETALIATE FOR THE REMOVAL OF
REPUBLICANS FROM THEIR
ASSIGNMENTS IN THE LAST
CONFERENCE AND HE DID.
I'M NEXT INVESTIGATED THE BIDEN
FAMILY THAT ALLEGED CRIMES
INCLUDES AUTHENTIC COLLUSION AND
COUNTLESS SHADY FOREIGN
DEALINGS.
THE ONLY ONE WHO DOESN'T THINK
THE BIG GUY IS JOE BIDEN IS
JOE BIDEN.
BECAUSE HE STOPPED THINKING A
1992.
THIS IS SLOW DOWN CONGRESS?
THE ANSWER IS I [BLEEP] HOPE SO.
KEEP HIM BUSY.
[APPLAUSE]
FIGHTING EACH OTHER, IT KEEPS
HIM OUT OF OUR LIVES.
WHILE THERE SLAPPING THE OUT OF
EACH OTHER WE GET TO CONTINUE TO
DO FUN THINGS.
LIKE COOKING ON GAS STOVES AND
DRINKING SHARP SHAKES THROUGH A
PLASTIC STRAW.
ALSO EVERY TIME CONGRESS AGREES
ON SOMETHING WE GET MORE WAR AND
MORE DEBT.
IF THE WEASELS KNOW THEY'RE
ALWAYS JUST A MIDTERM AWAY FROM
GETTING BUSTED, MAYBE WILL DO
BETTER AND THAT'S WITH THE
WINNING WILL GET YOU YOU NEED TO
IT TO THE OTHER SIDE
INVESTIGATE, PROSECUTE, THEY DID
THE LAST TIME BUT NOW IT'S THEIR
TERM TO BARREL AND LIKE I SAY
PAID BACK.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT GAS.
HE PLAYED A, AND I PAID A ACTOR
AND COMEDIAN ROB SCHNEIDER.
[APPLAUSE]
HE MIGHT LOOK LIKE A MILLION
BUCKS, BUT IS JUST A SINGLE
BILL.
AMERICA'S NEWSROOM COANCHOR,
BILL HEMMER.
[APPLAUSE]
SHE IS LIKE A NICKEL, SHINY,
SMALL, AND OFTEN FOUND HIDING
UNDER A COUCH CUSHION.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND FINALLY, HE HAS TROUBLE
SEEING EYE TO EYE WITH PEOPLE
AND GIRAFFES.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK IN THE
N.W.A. WORLD HEAVY WEIGHT
CHAMPION, TYRUS.
[APPLAUSE]
HOW ARE YOU ROB?
>> Rob: IT'S NICE TO HEAR JOE
GROGAN SINGING YOUR PRAISES.
SPAM I'LL TAKE ANYTHING I CAN
GET AT THIS POINT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I'M A VERY LONELY MAN ROB.
WE MAKE OF THE STUFF SO FAR?
THE SHIFTS EVERYTHING GOING WHAT
IS YOUR TAKE AWAY?
>> Rob: I THINK THAT, I THINK
THAT McCARTHY IS RIGHT.
I'M THINKING GET THE GLOBAL
ENTRY KNOWN HIM SAYING?
SORRY, WE GOT TO TAKE YOU AND
FANG BANGED TO GO TO THE OTHER
LINE.
WHERE THE X-RAY YOUR BALLS.
GET IN THERE.
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: HOW DID HE NOT KNOW
THAT SHE WASN'T A SPY?
WHO IS NAMED THAT AND NOT A SPY?
[LAUGHS]
>> Rob: ARE OF AN ANSWER FOR
THAT, THERE IS NO ANSWER.
>> Greg: IT SEEMS LIKE THE
REPUBLICANS ARE FIGHTING.
>> Rob: IT IS, WE ARE IN AN
INTERESTING PLACE RIGHT NOW WILL
BE ASKED TO HAVE AN OPPOSITION
WHO CAN DO SOMETHING WHICH IS
GOOD.
IT'S NOT BY A LOT, IT'S ENOUGH.
I'LL TAKE ENOUGH RIGHT NOW.
ANY OPPOSITION TO
AUTHORITARIANISM ON CARE WHAT
SIDE YOU'RE ON LET'S GO FOR IT.
>> Greg: EXACTLY YOU NEED TO
HAVE SUED TWO SIDES BILL AND YOU
HAVE TWO SIDES.
ONE THAT'S FUN AND WHEN THAT'S
FLIRTY.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE I AM
IT'S KIND OF FUNNY SEEING OMAR
GETTING KICKED OFF FOREIGN
AFFAIRS.
>> Bill: HE GOT KICKED OFF,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPEN?
AN EXTRAORDINARY THING HAPPENED
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
THEY HAD 365 MEMBERS THE HOUSE
LOOK FOR SOMETHING TOGETHER.
THAT INCLUDED A HUNDRED 46
DEMOCRATS.
THAT WAS FOR THE CHINA
COMMITTEE.
McCARTHY SAYS SHOULD LIVE
FOREVER.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> Rob: MAYBE HE WILL SEE FANG
FANG.
>> Bill: WANT TO KNOW WHY
UNITED STATES STOPPED AND MADE
MANUFACTURE ANYTHING MORE.
CAN WE MAKE LIKE A MINI MALL
STALL HERE IN AMERICA?
DOES THAT IS TO BE MET BY SOME
LEAD POISON IN CHINA?
>> Greg: ALL THE TOY DRUM SETS
ARE MADE IN CHINA IT'S LIKE --
I DO A LOT OF DEEP DIVES.
[LAUGHS]
IN CASE THE AUTHORITY STOP BY.
IF AN UNUSUAL SEARCH HISTORY, A
LOT OF TOYS.
>> Tyrus: HE MAKES A LOT OF
DONATIONS TO ORPHANAGES.
>> Bill: WILL SEE, THE HOUSE
ONLY HAS ONE-THIRD, ONE-THIRD OF
GOVERNMENT.
BUT ON THE IRS THING OF ZONING
87,000, WHAT YOU NEED 87,000 IRS
AGENTS?
WHAT ARE THEY GONNA DO ALL DAY?
HOW ARE THEY TO SPEND HER TIME?
THAT 2 MILLION MIGRANTS A YEAR
NOW.
THE IRS CAN I HAVE SOME TIME.
>> Rob: TRAY AUDITING LET'S
SEE IF THEY WANT TO COME TO THE
MIGRANTS WHEN YOU WANT TO START
AUDITING THEM.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: TYRUS?
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
EVENTS?
>> Tyrus: THE ANSWER BILL'S
QUESTION FOR THE INTRADO?
[BLEEP] WITH US.
THAT'S WITH THE INTRADO THERE
AND COME AFTER US.
SOME GLASS LIKE THAT HAPPEN.
WE GET EXCITED, BUT WE KNOW IT'S
CAN HAPPEN.
IT'S GONNA GET VETOED, OR IS HE
LIKES TO SAY WHAT?
[LAUGHS]
I'M SO SHOCKED THAT HE THOUGHT
THE SALVATION ARMY WAS A
SECRET SERVICE.
I CAN'T LET THAT GO.
>> Greg: YOUR NEED 24-HOUR
CIRCLE.
>> Tyrus: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT IS NOT AN EMERGENCY
MEETING WERE THE GENERALS?
I'LL SAY IT AGAIN, HE THOUGHT
THAT THE SALVATION ARMY WAS THE
SECRET SERVICE.
AND EVERYBODY'S OKAY WITH THIS?
>> Greg: WERE JUST NUMB TO IT
NOW.
>> Tyrus: IT'S BEYOND THE
PALE.
I THINK IT'S GREAT, GREG,
SOMETIMES LOVE BLINDS YOU.
WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE.
YOU KNOW, YOUR WHISTLE ASKING TO
KNOW THAT SHE SLEPT WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE ON THE FOOTBALL
TEAM.
YOU KNOW?
ONTO THE ONE GUY SHE DIDN'T TELL
NO, USUALLY GUY TO BREAK DOWN TO
THEM.
[LAUGHS]
THERE'S A SPOT OVER HERE.
THIS CAN HURT.
I THOUGHT HIS LINE WAS GREAT
THIS THAT I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG.
WHAT IS THE POINT?
YOU ARE COMPROMISED.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M NOT FIT
BECAUSE I WAS COMPROMISED.
BUT IT'S ON ABOUT ABOUT THE
MONEY.
THE AGENTS, THE WHOLE THING
ABOUT THE IRS AGENTS AND THE
THING WITH THE IRS WAS ABOUT
FUNDING DECIDE THEIR MONEY FOR
ELECTRONIC CAR STUFF THAT'S WHAT
THAT WAS ABOUT.
>> Greg: LAST WORD TO YOU KAT
ARE YOU EXCITED?
YOU THINK IT'S EVER CAN HAPPEN
IN YOUR LIFETIME THAT THE IRS
WILL BE ABOLISHED?
>> Kat: NO, IT'S NICE TO SAY
IT AND GOOD FOR THEM TO SAY THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THEY LIKE TO
SEE HAPPEN.
THEY ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S NO
SITUATION WHEN THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY HAPPEN.
LIKE YOU SAID, JOE BIDEN WOULD
VETO IT AND IT WOULDN'T EVEN GET
THAT FAR BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS
IN THE SENATE SO IT'S PRETTY
MUCH WHEN A MAN SAYS TO YOU
LIKE, I WOULD GO TO THE ENDS OF
THE EARTH FOR YOU.
IT'S NICE TO HEAR, BUT NOTES CAN
ASK YOU TO DO THAT.
THIS ISN'T THE LOWER THE RANKS.
YOU CAN JUST TAKE THE TRASH OUT.
[LAUGHS]
>> Tyrus: WE HAVE TO BE
CLEVER.
>> Kat: I LIKE TO SEE THEM
WORK ON THINGS LIKE POTENTIALLY
HAPPEN.
ANYBODY WHO WOULD VOTE FOR THAT,
THEN THERE'S SOMETHING SERIOUS.
>> Greg: WE WANT YOU TO TAKE
OUT THE TRASH NOT SOLVE WORLD
HUNGER.
>> Kat: I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE IRS ABOLISHED BUT IF ALL
REPUBLICANS IN CHARGE I FEEL
LIKE THEY DON'T HAVE THE BALLS
TO ACTUALLY DO IT.
>> Tyrus: UNLESS THEY PUT AT
THE END OF EVERYTHING THEY
WANTED AT THE END OF IT AND
ICE CREAM PARTY.
SO HE'S NOT GONNA VETO AN
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE, AND
ICE CREAM PARTY.
>> Tyrus: ABOLISHED THE
ICE CREAM PARTY AND ICE CREAM
FOR EVERYONE.
>> Rob: OWNED ABOUT THE GUNS
WERE THOSE GO?
THE IRS NEEDS GUNS AS MUCH AS
STRIPPERS NEED PhDs.
>> Tyrus: HOW DARE YOU THAT'S
WHY THEY DO IT TO GET THAT
PhD.
I HAVE FUNDED SEVERAL GENI